[Musique]
antiquaire depuis plusieurs années
Caroline marjoridon se fait connaître du
grand public grâce à l'émission affaire
conclue sur France 2
programme Caroline tient aussi une
boutique opus de Saint-Ouen une
véritable institution pour tous les
antiquaires c'est vraiment une maison en
fait je vis à Biron maintenant mais
pourtant habitué des lieux et là ce
weekend était victime d'une violente
agression sur le marché aux puces et
s'est faite dérobées plusieurs objets
dont un sac de luxe
je pense qu'on va les retrouver parce
qu'ils ont mis de l'ADN et ça ça va leur
faire un grand choc être victime d'une
attaque une mésaventure qui arrive à de
nombreuses célébrités Caroline
marjoridon témoigne après son agression
alors est devenu dangereux d'être une
célébrité aujourd'hui
c'est vrai voilà tu parleras à tes amis
plus tard s'il te plaît c'est vrai que
Caroline margueridon l'antiquaire donc
connu pour sa participation à faire
conclue était agressée et voler donc ce
dimanche à Saint-Ouen elle témoigne sur
ses réseaux sociaux compagnie de sa
fille elle tient d'abord à rassurer tout
le monde et montrer qu'elle est en forme
et de bonne humeur regarde
comment voulez-vous que
à la maison en disant maman va se
défendre et là j'ai un ami voilà
regardez ce qui vient de m'apporter
il y a écrit quoi il y a écrit quoi
parce que
je vois plus pour ta sale gueule
vous voyez c'est là qu'il faut se dire
on va relativiser
alors Gilles deux hommes l'ont attaqué
donc pour lui arracher sa montre c'est
ça
oui pour une fois toute seule alors
d'habitude d'aller toujours accompagner
au fameux marché Biron le marché de
Saint-Ouen là où elle a sa boutique et
puis ils ont voilà ils l'ont frappé ils
l'ont volé ils ont pris une montre un
sac à main de grande valeur 650 euros en
espèces et puis on fait mal quoi donc je
trouve son témoignage est admirable de
résilience et de courage
où on avait dérobé énormément de valeur
chez elle en l'année dernière je crois
d'accord ça fait beaucoup voilà c'est
vrai qu'on se pose la question comme ça
est-ce que les célébrités se sont de
plus en plus en danger oui non dites NON
Gilles oui
oui alors si vous le permettez moi je
vais simplement prendre mon exemple
personnel
et oui oui oui moi je viens de porter
plainte je dois dire que la police a été
parfaite ils m'ont accompagné ce qui
s'est passé une
énième salve de menace précise
avec des localisations qui font peur
vous habitez tout ça
et vous avez quoi des intimidations oui
et l'adresse diffusée voilà quoi sur les
réseaux sur les réseaux sur les réseaux
là c'était sur les réseaux ça m'était
déjà arrivé par courrier j'avais déjà
déposé plainte là c'était sur les
réseaux donc je suis allé déposer
plainte et le responsable de la police
il m'a appelé j'ai déposé plainte le
jeudi donc lui il a trouvé la plainte le
lundi matin il m'a appelé dans la foulée
on est resté 1h au téléphone et plantes
pourquoi pour
si vous le permettez
les menaces sont c'était clairement de
venir chez moi sans prendre à moi
et pas qu'à moi
j'ai été très inquiet toujours ouais
oui je suis inquiet une fois ici j'ai
pensé de suivi et moctarrer les équipes
m'ont appelé en demandant à la voiture
qui me ramenait de faire plusieurs tours
le policier m'a expliqué que quand je
rentrais chez moi fallait pas que je
rentre directement que je fasse des
tours que je sois prudent il m'a dit
aussi de faire attention
quand je prends les transports en commun
moi je veux pas changer de vie mais il
m'a dit il faut faire attention voilà
ouais
j'en parle avec émotion parce que il m'a
moi j'ai tendance à un peu être Brava et
lui là il m'a dit Gilles je vous appelle
je vous le dis clairement faites
attention alors ça c'est suite à vos
prises de position
c'est des salves sur les réseaux sociaux
qui sont liés à mes prises de position
c'est souvent les mêmes sujets c'est
quand je dis globalement je vais résumer
mais que les squatteurs on peut pas
aller jeter dehors comme ça c'est quand
je dis que
pédophiles sont ce qu'ils font et
monstrueux mais ce sont pas des monstres
voilà et à chaque fois c'est un
déchaînement sur derrière mais c'est
quoi donc c'est un déchaînement et on je
vais vous dire aussi quelque chose j'ai
trop je sais pas faire de comment on dit
de screen de d'écran là je suis nul
là-dedans et dimanche
je suis nul voilà non mais voilà
dimanche j'ai reçu un message je veux
pas vous donner la tonalité mais c'est
le plus ignoble message que j'ai jamais
reçu et depuis donc ça c'était dimanche
j'ai voulu le le montrer ici à aux
équipes mais il a été retiré par la
personne c'était tellement
ignoble que j'ai osé en parler à
personne et je me suis dit là c'est on
dépasse tout quoi j'ai failli venir vous
voir là vous auriez dû j'aurais dû ben
vous auriez oui mais j'aurais dû bien
sûr que j'aurais dû puis je sais que
dans ces cas-là vous êtes toujours là
mais j'ai pas le message était je vous
dis pas ce qui était le message il était
tellement ignoble que j'ai dit c'est
quoi sur quel réseau sur les sur insta
c'était non c'était Twitter Twitter et
j'ai dit si on en arrive là quand on
prend une position même si mes positions
suscitent des désaccords
[Musique]
et je sais que toi voilà c'est c'est
vrai que la célébrité et ton je veux
dire ton excellence dans l'émission fait
aujourd'hui que ça te fait ça te fait
des des soucis et et des gros problèmes
Mathieu vous l'avez dit à l'époque aussi
je crois que maintenant moi voilà
je le cherchais mais je pense que j'ai
bloqué la semaine dernière j'ai reçu
parce que quand c'est sur les réseaux on
s'en tape je vais la vérité je regarde
même pas les réseaux je vous dire un
tiers d'insultes un tiers de 1/3 de
gentillesse et en général un tiers de
messages aberrant je regarde même pas je
m'en tape mais quand c'est sur votre
texto et je crois que c'était à 10 jours
j'ai reçu ouais par texto dès que tu
descends de chez toi on sera là
en vrai
je l'ai bloqué j'ai passé pourquoi j'ai
mis nom parce que moi tu m'en as pas
parlé et tu vas faire quoi
le numéro c'est vrai mais en vrai je
vais te dire pourquoi j'ai mis non c'est
même si c'est une carte je t'explique
non
je le dis aussi mais c'est mon téléphone
je retrouve le mec d'où il l'a fait et
je vais le retrouver très vite mais en
l'occurrence c'était pas en bas ce qui
est toujours agaçant avec la police et
Dieu sait si je l'aime c'est que quand
tu vas aller voir et que tu leur dis
tout ça et te disent tant qu'il est pas
passé à l'acte c'est adorable mais bon
si tu vois en fait tant que tu es vivant
tu risques rien bon mais le truc c'est
que moi il y a deux choses qui me
rassure un peu la première c'est que on
a un petit peu plus accès et je le
reconnais c'est une vraie chance quand
on a une célébrité un petit peu connu on
a un petit peu plus accès à la police
quand je m'étais fait agresser par un
chauffeur de taxi j'ai appelé la BAC
4h après il était il était il était dans
les dans le commissariat et il y avait
un face à face c'est une chance
gigantesque sont pas la plupart des gens
qui vont porter plainte c'est une chance
gigantesque en revanche tu vois je te
dire quelque chose tu m'aurais dit à 10
ans je prends la garde du corps mais
j'aurais été grotesque garde du corps
c'est Madonna je me serais balai avec un
garde du corps mais ton copains
cette année j'y pense je vais le payer
sur ma société parce que du coup tu as
le droit de prendre soin de la société
et non pas parce que je suis une star
mais parce que j'ai peur alors quand
j'ai mis non c'est juste parce que je
suis sauvé entre guillemets un petit peu
par le fait qu'on est voilà et parce que
j'ai les moyens peut-être de me défendre
et ça va me rassurer mais tout le monde
les a pas merci d'ailleurs un petit peu
grâce à toi mais si on avait dit un jour
je ferai le métier
si pour faire le métier que tu aimes le
métier dont tu rêvais petit un jour tu
auras un garde du corps parce que
contrairement à ce qu'on pense c'est
très drôle trois jours parce que tu te
prends pour une rockstar mais c'est
insupportable tu as quelqu'un qui est là
tout le temps et tout c'est pas drôle du
tout un jour tu aurais ça franchement
j'ai pas cru revenir sur un truc que
vous venez de dire vous avez dit c'est à
cause de moi c'est pas du tout à cause
de vous Cyril
qui est exac
épidermique et où toute prise de
position va faire que évidemment un
Français sur deux va être d'accord avec
vous
et d'ailleurs je voudrais vous en
remercier et Lionel stanle également
parce que en l'occurrence vous m'avez
mis à garde du corps parce que il y a
quelqu'un qui est venu ici pour s'en
prendre à moi physiquement qui a été
interpellé par là-bas qui est venu à
deux reprises à la deuxième reprise il a
été arrêté et qui voulait je sais que ça
vous a beaucoup énormément bouleversé
parce que je ne m'y attendais absolument
pas parce que je pensais justement qu'on
est dans une démocratie où on peut
débattre y compris ne pas être d'accord
y compris ne pas être d'accord de façon
extrêmement forte je vais vous dire je
pense avec ça ça rejoint aussi même les
et je le redis encore vous allez me dire
où il est fou il accent en tête mais ça
rejoint aussi les donnant de leçons qui
qui nous reprochent parfois d'avoir une
jeune fille voilée émission ou bien de
recevoir un représentant du
rassemblement national ça aussi c'est
aussi de l'intolérance et et c'est voilà
c'est c'est aussi la liberté
d'expression il se prône tous la liberté
d'expression tous les bien-pensants tous
les donneurs de leçons mais aujourd'hui
la liberté d'expression la plus claire
la plus et la plus poussée elle est dans
Touche pas à mon poste je suis désolé il
y a pas une émission ou où on invite
autant de gens différents et autant de
témoignages différents et donc c'est
vrai que ça aussi je vous dis les gens
et je le dis pour moi les responsables
aussi ce sont ceux qui mettent de
l'huile sur le feu comme les les
biensants qui font des tweets les Sofia
Aram de France Inter qui fait des tweets
très très violents sur vous sur les ce
qui se passe dans l'émission alors que
voilà personne la connaît elle essaie
d'être drôle à chaque fois c'est à côté
et c'est ni drôle mais c'est dangereux
donc ça c'est loin c'est dangereux et
quand on s'en prend à eux
ça c'est sur nous que ça retombe c'est
un moment tant que tu sais plus quoi
faire mais à un moment comme je dis un
moment ça on va on va être obligé d'être
plus méchant que et là ça va être plus
compliqué Jean-Mi oui alors évidemment
en préambule il y a beaucoup plus
d'avantages que d'inconvénients
encore quand même j'avais des menaces
mais dernièrement j'étais victime d'un
tentation de chambre pas d'une tentative
de chantage d'extors de fond quoi parce
que je m'étais livré j'étais célibataire
à ce moment là et évidemment qu'on est
quand on est un peu connu on reçoit
beaucoup plus de messages comme par
hasard de jeunes filles jolies qui vous
écrivent que quand vous étiez
voilà et du coup je m'étais célibataire
j'avais commencé à échanger avec cette
jeune fille là on s'est échangé des
photos etc et moi j'étais en pleine
confiance parce que vraiment c'était ça
faisait tellement de temps que c'était
monté progressivement qu'on s'est
échangé le message on se racontait nos
vies de façon plus intime etc jusqu'au
jour où quelqu'un de public m'a appelé
un journaliste de public que je
connaissais un peu m'a appelé me disant
est-ce que c'est normal qu'on reçoit des
photos de toi plutôt intime à la
rédaction etc etc en fait je me du coup
j'ai écrit la personne qui tout de suite
là sachant qu'elle était dévoilée
qu'elle était révélée m'a dit qu'elle
réclamait 25000 euros pour cesser de
d'essayer de vendre ses photos là au
magazine au magazine en caisse au
magazine voilà les magazines m'ont dit
de façon on ne fera jamais paraître ce
genre de photos mais sache que ça
circule qu'il y a des gens qui conseille
de les vendre j'ai contacté la police
qui a essayé de donner rendez-vous des 7
pièges de cette personne là qui prenait
vraiment des précautions et des
téléphones avec des cartes des cartes
prépayées etc ils ont donné un
rendez-vous la personne avait dû se
méfier ils ont pas réussi à la choper et
après ça c'est un peu calmé mais
normalement j'ai vraiment je me suis dit
j'ai quand même eu un peu peur parce que
ça devenait vraiment très très intime
quoi
au bout d'un moment comme elles sont
jamais exécutés tu te dis on m'a dit si
tu si tu descends
et le problème c'est que il suffit d'une
fois et il suffit d'une fois bien sûr et
c'est ça le problème et après tu tu
risques d'être traumatisé la vie
qu'on se plaignent d'avoir de la
notoriété
moi il m'est arrivé des choses mais
délicieuses un jour je suis avec Raphaël
Mezrahi
Tarak Benamar dans ses studios tu sais
en Tunisie et on tombe sur une dame qui
s'arrête devant Raphaël et moi elle dit
mon Dieu quand je vais dire à ma fille
que j'ai croisé Monsieur Michel Boujenah
et Monsieur Jean-Marie Bigard elle va
pas en revenir et Raphaël il est signé
Michel Boujenah
c'était très drôle mais toi tu tu lâches
rien non mais c'est vrai le jour où je
lâcherai je vous dirai Cyril je peux
plus le faire c'est pas la peine tu t'es
déjà posé la question ou pas
dimanche quand j'ai reçu le message je
me suis dit est-ce que je vais pas
appeler Siri non
il était ouais c'est le genre de message
que vous le recevez vous dites ça sert
plus rien quoi une fois qu'on reçoit ça
c'était tellement abominable
ignoble vous dites mais après il y a
quoi donc je me suis dit est-ce que tu
es capable de continuer à donner ton
avis sinon lucinement taper le Cyril et
tu lui écoutez Cyril écoute Cyril je
pense que tu connais écoute c'est vrai
je pense que là je vais plus donner mon
avis être moi-même donc il faut
peut-être voir ce qu'on peut faire et
puis je me suis dit que il fallait être
plus fort que le message bien sûr non
mais c'est vrai oui oui c'est vrai
Guillaume je t'ai vu un peu non moi
alors je suis très touché par les
témoignages notamment celui de Gilles
qui est mon ami mais je comprends pas
pourquoi on ramène tout à la célébrité
il y a pas que les célébrités qui se
font agresser il y a pas que les
célébrités qui se font tabasser non mais
d'accord mais est-ce que c'est dangereux
d'être sur une célébrité je ne sais pas
si c'est plus dangereux que d'être
quelqu'un dans la société d'aujourd'hui
qui est violente et on entend plus ces
célébrités se plaindre et moi j'en ai un
peu marre de voir des célébrités
pleurniché en ce moment sur les réseaux
dès qu'il aura une arrivée un truc je me
suis fait menacer
aujourd'hui n'a pas le pouvoir de
médiatiser cette affaire et d'en faire
parler les réseaux sociaux on a reçu
énormément ici je suis désolé il faut
quand même rappeler alors là je suis pas
d'accord
il y en a beaucoup en France
malheureusement il y en a plein et je
trouve qu'il faut quand même dire la
vérité être célèbre aujourd'hui être
médiatisé c'est énormément davantage
tout le monde est sympa
la question
belle monde qui voit des choses mais
donc ils savent que s'ils viennent vers
toi normalement ils auront quelque chose
ils ont connu dans la rue tu en sais
rien mais pour ça je dis juste qu'on
entend plus les célébrités se plaindre
que ça veut dire
ça du côté positif et se dire bah qui
parle pour les gens qui ne peuvent pas
parler aussi parce que là le fait d'une
manière très digne très classe elle en
rigole je sais pas comment elle fait
parce que moi j'en rigolerai pas donc
c'est pour te dire la force de caractère
de cette femme et moi je la trouve
extraordinaire justement de le dire j'ai
répondu oui Kelly pourquoi moi j'ai
répondu oui parce que j'ai eu aussi des
expériences négatives comme comme mes
camarades et et ouais
en fait je pense que le fait des réseaux
il faut aussi apprendre à pas poster en
direct je pense quand quelqu'un de un
petit peu reconnu
parce que moi j'ai fait l'expérience par
exemple d'un homme qui me retrouvait
tous les soirs après l'émission à
Boulogne et puis quand je me retrouvais
parce que de base j'habite dans le sud
de la France et quand je me retrouvais
dans le sud de la France et ben là par
contre il était vraiment en bas de chez
moi et quand tu vois le mec écrire en
direct et les tu le vois de à ta fenêtre
écrire sur les réseaux et je le voyais
mettre entrée et voir en direct les
messages de haine qu'il écrivait sur moi
en direct en bas de ma fenêtre donc
c'est vrai que quand tu es confronté à
la personne physique et que tu dis que
tu descends en bas de chez toi et que
bah tu as envie de fuir ou lui sauter
dessus tu sais pas quoi faire tellement
tu as la haine de la personne et tu dis
que tu te fais harceler et que la
personne elle tente elle tombe elle
t'attend en bas de chez elle et en même
temps tu as ta famille chez toi et tu
sais pas comment réagir et j'ai eu la
chance je reviens sur ce que dit Mathieu
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir la police de
de mon côté assez réactive donc à chaque
fois que je le voyais en bas de chez moi
je les appelais et il venait le
récupérer mais il y a un moment donné
mais quand il était c'est ça quand il te
dise autant qu'il ne passe pas à
l'action
je leur disais mais oui mais moi j'ai
peur j'ai pas envie qu'il passe à
l'action donc en fait c'est délicat et
c'est vrai que c'est une fille seule
faut pas oublier ça aussi c'est une
vraie chance quand un garçon et Gilles a
des enfants aussi quand on a des enfants
on est beaucoup plus inquiet et pardon
je veux pas du tout dévoiler ta vie
privée mais c'est vrai tu as aussi
quelqu'un qui est souvent avec toi qui
est chauffeur et qui bien sûr et tout ça
donc t'es pas
moi ce que j'aime pas là sur la manière
de mettre en scène tout ça c'est ah là
là je suis une célébrité ça m'est tombé
dessus
tu as voulu être honnête la 99% des gens
connus l'ont voulu l'ont chercher si tu
veux pas alors tu te retires et tu te
retrouves mais c'est fou de dire ça par
contre
on entend moins les stars dire ah bah ce
soir j'ai une table gratuite au resto
merci mon salaire je prends une balle
voilà
ce sont les risques du métier c'est tout
il faut les accepter je fais pas
l'apologie
mais qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
travers de la médaille c'est quand tu
fais un métier un petit peu célèbre le
revers de la médaille c'est l'accepter
de te faire casser la gueule de te faire
je sais ce que j'ai reçu une fois après
cette émission c'est je pense que ta
mère se retourne tous les soirs dans sa
tombe sale [ __ ] voilà ce que je reçois
c'est le regard on reçoit Mathieu mais
ça c'est pas possible
pour recevoir ça de télé et tu as un
chauffeurs
je suis complètement d'accord avec
Mathieu bien sûr tu peux pas tu peux tu
peux pas écrire tu peux pas y lire ça
aussi tu sais c'est un métier qu'on fait
on se retrouve pas des vies je suis pas
médecin et tout on fait un métier je
pense qu'on a pas le droit de se
plaindre
on fait pas bien d'autres métiers on a
le droit de nous le dire on a pas le
droit de nous menacer les enfants
parce que vous recevez aussi beaucoup
d'amour beaucoup de gens qui vous font
des compliments il y a des gens pour qui
il y a des gens pour qui vous êtes tarte
une caresse pas du tout mais je ne dis
pas il y a un peu nuant je fais pas
l'apologie de ça il y a des gens pour
qui vous êtes tellement loin qu'en fait
il balance des insultes ils disent bah
ils le lira jamais
de quoi tu parles heureusement
elles ne sont pas mises exécution
si j'avais pas été incroyable si j'ai
pas été connu pardon je ne crois pas
être totalement efféminé personne
n'aurait su que j'étais gay et quand je
prenne un taxi ça passe et bah moi
tu dis Boulogne s'il vous plaît jamais à
Boulogne j'amène un petit [ __ ] comme toi
c'est quoi c'est pas c'est de
l'homophobie et c'est dégueulasse bien
sûr Mathieu mais personne
a montré ta gueule partout à la télé
raconter ta vie par toi la télé donc
quand tu le fais c'est grave c'est grave
plaisir
je trouve que tu es d'une démagogie
confondante je comprends pas parce
qu'effectivement toi tu sors le soir
comme ça tu as un chauffeur qui t'attend
donc ça veut dire que tu es pas du tout
comment dire en contact avec avec la
vraie vie finalement tu es complètement
hors-sol avec des mais si ça touche pas
en fait tu vois bien que Mathieu il te
raconte qu'il est paniqué quand tu
rentres chez lui tout seul et que Kelly
elle est paniqué quand elle va chez elle
dans le sud tu vois bien que c'est moi
il y a eu un moment donné où j'ai eu
très très peur à TPMP j'ai eu très très
peur parce que on a mis l'adresse de ma
mère on a mis l'adresse de ma fille on a
dit l'école de ma fille on a montré les
horaires de l'école de ma fille donc
j'ai été en panique et heureusement que
j'avais des GO qui s'occupe de la
sécurité pour me protéger pour me
rassurer et lui contrairement à ce que
tu as fait il m'a dit de absolument
porter plainte de pas laisser ça comme
ça même un sms il dit il faut absolument
marcher
le coup tu vois qu'il y a une sorte de
main courante et tout ça parce que c'est
trop facile
toutes les semaines quoi
Géraldine
très pour le coup interventionniste et
j'ai trouvé ça très rapidement d'être
epic Guillaume il me semble pas que nous
soyons larmoyant que nous soyons sur le
ton de oh là là c'est difficile pas du
tout Guillaume on accélère très bien
tous bien sûr et on en a les avantages
et les revers mais là on parle de mise
en danger Guillaume là c'est de la mise
en danger toutes les expériences qu'on
vous raconte les les uns et les autres
c'est la crainte de notre intégrité
physique de nos proches sur le lieu de
travail au domicile pendant le trajet
Guillaume on est sur un tout autre
registre et là vous pouvez pas le
banaliser ça encore une fois je dis pas
que c'est bien de se faire menacer de se
faire insulter j'ai juste qu'on vous
faites une story pour dire oh là là j'ai
reçu un message très méchant sur
Instagram faites aussi des story quand
vous dites je me fais inviter gratos en
vacances
mais une vie pour les gens parce que
quand on rentre ici tu sais ce qu'on
fait on se barre on arrive chez nous il
est 22h on a un jogging on trouve
et tes trucs gratuits mais à quel moment
s'il y a un ici là qui nous regarde là
un hôtel un machin un bateau une bagnole
souvent je dis ça pour déconner mais tu
crois que j'ai des trucs gratuits mais
il y en a plein de bravo
il achète toutes les affaires qu'il a il
a mais tout mais tout bien sûr
jamais rien de gratuit
je ne cautionne pas c'est 18h
mais c'est pas les avantages
tu vas nous faire croire que tu es un
smicard et quel Raphaël
sur leur Smart j'ai de l'argent j'ai une
vie normale franchement je dis la vérité
alors il y a des cas évidemment
extrêmement graves et encore une fois je
ne cautionne pas du tout
mais j'arrive pas je n'arrive pas à
planifier le projet
il y a un de nous qui se fait tabasser
tu diras quoi ah ben c'est le revers de
la maison
vous n'avez pas de nuancier dans ce
cas-là qu'est-ce qu'il faut que tu dis
il faut que tu as passé bah tu dois
poster mais il faut mettre aussi il y a
des gens qui m'ont dit que j'étais
génial poster dans mes il est très
naturel tu es un garçon très intelligent
et tu sais game je t'aime beaucoup mais
il y a des moments où je sais pas ce qui
se passe dans l'émission C'est comme le
jour où tu as déclaré un jour je préfère
sauver mon chien que je connais mais un
bébé que je ne connais pas maman qui
déconne pas parce qu'on est pas d'accord
avec mais Mathieu ce n'est pas parce
qu'on est d'accord
là c'est du bon sens je suis pas
d'accord avec toi et désolé tu ne me
fais pas de la peine mais pardon il y a
des gens qui me font de la peine toi tu
me fais pas de la peine voilà
aucun sens pour toi c'est tout non mais
non
plutôt qu'un bébé
bien sûr
on n'est pas d'accord avec toi qu'on est
taré qu'on est fou laisse avoir une
opinion Mathieu
dans le monde sauve un chien plutôt
il a raison là-dessus c'était c'est bien
Raymond qu'on a pas entendu as-tu
Guillaume mélange en fait ils vont
emmener les gens là-dedans là on parle
que de la célébrité là célébrité c'est
ce qu'ils a c'est ce qui c'est ce qui
vit lui quand il se fait harceler avec
des propos homophobes c'est ce qui a
vécu Valérie c'est ce que vigile et moi
je pense que c'est par rapport au piano
c'est par rapport au thé en fait si tu
es à TPMP vu oui évidemment c'est
dangereux mais je crois pas que j'ai le
boulot qui soit célèbre je crois pas
qu'on l'emmerde Jean-Luc Reichmann je
crois pas qu'on l'emmerde Nagui je crois
pas qu'on l'emmerde il y a des mecs ils
peuvent ils peuvent faire toute une
carrière où ils sont célèbres et c'est
pas dangereux pour eux tout dépend
des choses en direct ici nous on prend
des risques on est d'abord en direct on
peut pas couper là ce que je suis en
train de dire si c'est une véritable
connerie et ben ce sera une véritable
connerie en plus de ça on a des gens
derrière qui font des comme tu disais
les bobos là qui font des articles en
disant nous on est d'extrême droite donc
derrière quand on va dans la rue moi
depuis que je fais TPMP c'est récent
c'est pas vieux le truc qui m'a le plus
blessé c'est quand dans la rue on vient
m'agresser en me disant que je suis
d'extrême droite j'ai mais qui t'a dit
que d'extrême droite et juste passer à
droite dans le sud la journaliste non
mais c'est aussi une agression quand le
mec vient me voir il me dit tu es
d'extrême droite c'est une journaliste
qui a dit qu'on avait reçu pas mal de
gens d'extrême droite mais c'est normal
donc les mecs comprennent pas ils font
des dégâts c'est incroyable exactement
je sors de la Factory que je vais que je
marche et des dégustation pour moi parce
que juste pour mettre un titre
accrocheur on fait des dégâts énormes je
marche je sors de la Factory je marche à
ma voiture parce que bon pour des
raisons je sais pas j'ai pas de parking
je sais toujours pas pourquoi je marche
jusqu'à maintenant j'ai un mec qui est
là avec une avec un sweat et qui me sort
un pistolet en plastique ou un vrai et
qui me dit [ __ ] d'extrême droite et
qui me braque avec un flingue tout ça
alors il est peut-être en plastique le
flingue je m'en fous je lui dis quand je
vous dis que les bobos dépêche-toi
vous avez avec le France Inter vous avez
connu la rue j'ai appelé Diego Diego il
m'a dit va porter plainte j'ai pas le
temps pour ces conneries il m'a dit si
il faut peut-être une connerie vous avez
bloqué la rue j'ai dit oh mais tire
maintenant ou va te faire [ __ ] je suis
reparti j'ai fait blanc mais non c'est
la vérité cette femme là sommes là quand
elle dit qu'on est d'extrême droite elle
se rend pas compte que derrière
donc voilà c'est très grave exactement
les mêmes mais bien sûr mais moi je m'en
fous prenez de l'eau
sur Instagram
[Rires]
pour rester sur Caroline Caroline et
c'est malheureux qu'elle soit agressé
pour ça parce qu'elle n'exibles à
l'exhib ces montres elle est dans à
faire conclue elle exhib de l'argent à
l'exhib des voitures de sport des fois
sur Instagram c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
partis la chercher donc ça devient
dangereux parce qu'elle a mais
malheureusement en plus elle a choisi un
canal à choisir un canon de dire voilà
moi c'est ça ma vie voilà nous notre vie
c'est ça mais c'est très grave ce que tu
as vécu toi c'est très grave porte de
l'émission avec un petit jouet en 6
lettres un flingue qui est peut-être un
vrai frein un flingue peut-être pas on
n'en sait rien c'est pas parce qu'il a
pris position dans une émission ou que
au même titre que moi il y a un type qui
vient parce qu'il cherche à venir me
casser la gueule parce que j'ai pris
position dans l'émission
je sais pas si je vais rester moi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis tellement fier de cette émission
et je le dis vraiment mais il faut et là
vous allez voir tout le monde va dire
c'est incroyable tu as raison il y a
plein d'autres accès pourquoi mais non
pas en direct non non dans 20 ans dans
50 ans donc on se rappellera croyez
vraiment je dis la vérité vous prenez un
moment qu'on se rappellera quotidien non
il faudrait vraiment qu'on se rappellera
de c'est à vous non je vous dis la
vérité je dis la vérité qu'est-ce qu'on
se rappellera de quoi de TPMP on se
rappellera de vous alors c'est vrai que
prenez énormément de risques mais c'est
vrai que les gens vous serez toujours
dans la mémoire collective je dis la
vérité vous croyez vraiment qu'on va se
rappeler d'une autre émission des des
vous allez me dire il est peut-être fou
mais est-ce que je dis la vérité ou pas
forcément qu'on va se rappeler le
quotidien même si c'est pour une très
bonne émission c'est très bien vous
croyez vraiment comment on va se
rappeler c'est à vous jamais de la vie
on dira ouais ouais je crois qu'il
faisait un truc mais j'ai envie
franchement bah bien sûr évidemment bah
oui mais il se passe quelque chose c'est
comme la seule émission en direct tout
simplement qui a tenu le coup en direct
et d'ailleurs pour ne rien vous cacher
tout à l'heure on va parler de Dieudonné
autant vous dire que moi c'est panique à
bord parce qu'il y a des thèmes je sais
c'est hyper compliqué super
accidentogène je suis comme ça c'est la
nitroglycéride il y a des thèmes on peut
pas les araignées
sur la vie normalement
le premier truc regarde la mission parce
qu'on sait que c'est plutôt des sujets
légers on va tous directement aux trois
derniers sujets en se disant sur quoi ça
va être chaud aujourd'hui il est fou
Dieudonné qui demande pardon
on sait que c'est essentiellement super
super accidentogène par rapport à ce
qu'on va dire par rapport aux nuances
qu'on va pouvoir apporter ou pas par
rapport à comment les gens vont réagir
et tout ça avec toi si tu trouves que
c'est le revers de la médaille mais le
revers de la médaille si c'est de devoir
déménager c'est que nos enfants soient
menacés avec les écoles identifier des
enfants et tout ça
j'ai juste besoin de vivre ce soir
on dit presque pas qu'on mérite ce qui
nous arrive franchement
entre ce que vous dites là et votre vrai
vie le coup je parle pas de moi je parle
de vous attends moi j'ai fréquenté pas
mal de gens ici je suis sorti avec
Raymond avec Jean-Michel avec plein de
trucs non mais non mais voilà de l'argon
quand on sort ensemble j'ai pas
l'impression que que tu en danger de
mort vous êtes en dangereux tu vas
arrêter un peu quand tu vas au César
manger des gnocchis mais justement au
fromage c'est justement c'est parce que
c'est ça l'ordi aussi
je prends le métro là ben pourquoi
tu es bien content d'avoir d'avoir une
belle dame moi je me plaint pas la boîte
de mon père et moi je ne me pleure pas
[Applaudissements]
je me plains pas moi Jean-Michel pardon
et désolé les gars les gars pardon vous
êtes connus les gens vous aime beaucoup
les gens qui viennent vous voir dans la
rue vous aime beaucoup vous gagnez tous
extrêmement bien votre vie vous ne me
ferez pas peur
arrête de dire des choses
tu connais rien de ma vie bah si je
connais ta vie bah non pardon tu habites
dans un T1 au fin fond de la France
arrête tes conneries chacun pourra nous
donner son salaire
non mais est-ce que tu veux
incroyable
58% oui
41%, non mais bon après il y a non et
non je comprends les gens qui disent non
aussi après il y a le nombre Guillaume
qui est un nom un nom il est en train de
dire et là je reconnais c'est pas
dangereux d'une célébrité si tu as de
l'oseille pour te protéger voilà c'est
pas parce que tu es une célébrités
mais quand elle fait un peu de télé dès
que tu dis avec quelqu'un l'addition
c'est toujours pour toi on pense que si
tu fais de la télé forcément mais c'est
un
supportable aller travailler